joe burrow is the quarterback for the
bengals and as we know when it comes to
any important social issue uh we always
want to hear from athletes because
they're they're experts in everything
we need we need their opinion on all
societal
issues if you're not going to outlaw
everything you got to at least make it
harder to
to get those
those crazy guns that everybody's using
um
i don't think you should be able to just
walk in there and buy one you got to be
able to go through
you know a rigorous process to to be
able to buy something like that i think
well said uh we want to we want to keep
the crazy gun
so the crazy guns we got to keep away
from people i think is that's in the
cons that's in the second amendment
isn't it it's in there because it says
you know shall not be infringed right to
bear arms but then it also says um
unless it's a crazy gun and then in
which case it can be you know uk don't
have the right to that so that's it
might be an invisible anchor there's a
lot of stuff in invisible link
in the constitution invisible ink